bonjour à tous Nous sommes très heureux
de vous retrouver en ce mardi matin avec
Annie et d'accueillir Beranger Polti
nouvelle porte-parole de notre famille
politique les républicains Beranger qui
est député des Ardennes depuis 2002
parlementaire chevrenis pleine
d'expérience qui représente un peu comme
Annie le grand test quand même he moi je
suis le représentant du centre de la
France conseillère départemental des
ardenes aussi et puis qui a de multiples
compétences sur des sujets de qui
passionnent les Français je relisais sur
toutes les questions liées aux emplois
par exemple familiaux les emplois à
domicile tu avais commis un rapport sur
le sur le sujet et donc qui pourra nous
accompagner tous les mardis donc on est
très heureux de voir notre équipe de
porte-parole C Aué avec des profils et
des sensibilités très complémentaires et
donc je te laisse la parole
cherberanger merci merci beaucoup donc
c'est à moi que revient l'honneur de de
d'entamer cette conférence de presse
aujourd'hui par le classique agenda
prévisionnel que qui n'est pas forcément
très chargé cette semaine et donc bah
qui commence aujourd'hui par cette
conférence de presse et ce soir une
commission exécutive à 18h et il est
prévu pour vendredi à 16h30 une réunion
publique en présence d'Eric vert
secrétaire général des républicains à
betéthune donc voilà là pour l'agenda je
sais pas si on laisse une petite part
aux questions entre chaque ordre du jour
non a priori non
donc à la fin d'accord donc deè sujet
c'est le sujet des des primaires qui
arrive à sa fin en tout cas sur les
candidatures donc je rappelle les
différents concurrents qui ont été
validés donc Jean-François Copé François
Fillon Alain Jupé Nathalie cossus
comorisé Bruno Le Maire HERV Marie
Nicolas Sarkozi tout cela au titre des
partis du parti républicain euh au titre
du Parti Chrétien Démocrate nous avons
Jean-Frédéric Poisson il est prévu une
mise au point finale le 21 septembre par
la Haute Autorité de façon à pouvoir
clore définitivement le le nom de des
candidats euh voilà parce qu'il
semblerait que il peut y avoir quelques
candidatures qui se fassent directement
auprès de la haute a autorité un s'est
rapproché des du parti républicain et
puis peut-être d'autres directement
auprès de la Haute Autorité mais ça ça
sera pour le 21 septembre voilà le point
du jour suivant je pense que c'est Annie
non c'est toi comme vous voulez comme
vous
voulez merci beaucoup Beranger nous
voulions outre les questions liées à
l'agenda et puis à la primaire que
vienent vient d'évoquer
beréranger commencer ce ce point presse
par ce que nous considérons nous chez
les républicains comme un véritable
scandale d'État ce sont les révélations
du Figaro ce matin sur la
politique migratoire voulu par le
gouvernement si on regarde bien ce qui
est révélé par vos confrères du Figaro
si regarde bien tout ce que nous savons
depuis des mois et des mois sur la
situation à Calais nous savons que la
situation est explosive nous dénonçons
conférence de presse après conférence de
presse mais aussi au Parlement et dans
l'ensemble des des des des médias depuis
plusieurs mois l'impuissance de l'État
c'est-à-dire que aujourd'hui nous nous
le rappelons sans cesse le pouvoir n'a
plus le pouvoir et la puissance publique
est devenue impuissance publique
c'est-à-dire que nous sommes tous
engagés en politique parce que nous
considérons que le pouvoir politique à
la charge la responsabilité la mission
profonde et noble d'apporter des
solutions des réponses concrètes à des
problèm réels qui inquièteent nos
compatriotes et on voit premier scandale
sur la question de Calais et de la
répartition annoncée des migrants sur
l'ensemble du territoire national
premier scandale c'est le principe
politique quelle est la mission première
de l'homme public de la puissance
politique c'est de résoudre un problème
et chacun comprend à travers la volonté
du ministre de l'Intérieur révélé par Le
Figaro ça n'est pas de résoudre le
problème de Calais c'est de d'amplifier
de développer ce problème il y avait un
Calais il y aura avec la politique
voulue par le gouvernement des centaines
de Calais sur le territoire national et
nous dénonçons cet état de faite parce
que évidemment si on voulait créer les
prémisses d'une guerre civile dans
notutre pays en opposant les uns et les
autres les élus euh les uns les les avec
le leurs collègues et leurs confrères la
population sur l'ensemble du territoire
on ne s'y prendrait pas autrement ce
scandale nous souhaitons le dénoncer
pour que l'ensemble de nos compatriotes
et l'ensemble des élus locaux en
prennent conscience sans paraphraser
bossouet on verra d'ailleurs sur cette
sur ce sujet sans doute demain les
hommes politiques venir déplorer les
effets dont ils ont chéri les causes
c'est très important que chacun de nos
compatriotes prenne conscience de ce
scandale qui est en train de grandir
dans notre pays donc prier scandale le
principe politique deuxème scandale le
principe d'application de cette
politique voulue par le gouvernement
révélé par Le Figaro il est dit de
manière très claire dans cette note que
le gouvernement demande au préfet de
faire remonter les places disponibles
département par département sans aucune
concertation avec les maires et les élus
locaux nous sommes donc dans une sorte
de dictature migratoire de dictat imposé
par l'État à rebours de la démocratie
locale à rebours de la légitimité du
suffrage universel c'est-à-dire de la
possibilité pour les élus locaux qui
représentent leurs concitoyens leur
population de pouvoir choisir et décider
en connaissance de cause donc le le le
sur ce sur ce sujet il nous faut avec
beaucoup de de force de détermination de
courage dénoncer cette situation et
apporter nous des solution concrète la
solution pour régler Calais n'est pas de
créer d'autres calis sur l'ensemble du
terr terire national nous avons nous
chez les républicains des propositions
claires et fortes depuis plusieurs mois
la première c'est évidemment de de
renouer des discussions fortes et
avancées avec nos partenaires
britanniques on sait très bien que la
question de Calais ne peut pas se
résoudre uniquement à l'ône d'une vision
franco-française et qu' nous faudra au
niveau européen et dans un partenariat
assumé avec nos amis britanniques
trouver une solution pour un centre
d'accueil de migrants de l'autre côté de
la Manche côté britannique premièrement
deuxièmement il va nous falloir enfin
dans notre pays et au niveau européen
réfléchir sérieusement au rétablissement
des contrôles aux frontières nationales
de manière provisoire tant qu'un
Schengen 2 c'est-à-dire une nouvelle
politique de contrôle des frontières
européennes une nouvelle politique
migratoire voit le jour il nous faudra
aussi c'est la demande croissante de nos
compatriotes et de nos concitoyens avoir
une politique du droit d'asile beaucoup
plus efficace et beaucoup plus rapide
dans un premier temps et puis
deuxièmement avoir aussi l'audace et la
volonté à rebours de la politique
gouvernementale
d'expulser ceux qui n'ont rien à faire
sur le territoire national et vous
connaissez les chiffres - 20 % depuis le
début de l'année depuis janvier 2016 de
reconduite à la frontière et enfin avoir
une véritable politique courageuse là
aussi pour mettre fin à à l'appel d'air
et ça passera évidemment c'est ce que
propose le programme des républicains et
puis la quasi- totalité d'ailleurs des
candidat à la primaire c'est une
politique sur la question des
allocations sociales euh qui de qui
doivent être réservé à celles et ceux
qui ont un projet de vie un travail et
un logement sur le territoire national
tant que cette politique de gestion de
maîtrise assumée apaisée mais volontaire
de la politique migratoire ne sera pas
mise en œuvre nous serons confrontés à
des à des phénomènes d'une violence
inouï et nous verrons les Français se
détourner de plus en plus du pouvoir
politique donc pour conclure nous
souhaitons nous non pas une politique de
l'impuissance publique mais nous voulons
rétablir l'autorité de la puissance
politique en redonnant le pouvoir au
pouvoir le pouvoir de décider d'agir et
d'apporter enfin des réponses concrètes
et courageuses aux problématiques
rencontrées par nos
compatriotes merci Guillaume j'ajoute si
tu le permets que l'État islamique a
théorisé sa stratégie en Europe
terroriser les
attentats épuiser les forces de police
et de gendarmerie et diviser les
Français et sur ce dernier point on voit
bien que la façon dont le gouvernement
s'y prend dans la répartition
d'immigrants et de nature manifestement
à jeter les Français les uns contre les
autres et ça c'est très grave parce que
et bien nous nous en sortirons pas ainsi
alors moi je vais vous parler d'Alstom
qui est un dossier majeur de la rentrée
un dossier à la fois économique et
industriel et un dossier social et
éminemment politique euh vous connaissez
les faits l'annonce il y a quelques
jours par la direction d'Alstom de
l'abandon du site de Belfort de la
partie production et
ingénierie ne serait maintenu à
bellefort sur les 500 emplois qu'une
soixantaine à une centaine d'emplois sur
la maintenance alors cette nouvelle a
évidemment fait l'effet d'une d'une
bombe et a motivé une réunion
interministérielle en urgence hier de
laquelle il n'est rien sorti de concret
sinon quelques
engagements mais sur lesquels on peut
nourrir des doutes si l'on songe aux
engagements du candidat Hollande pendant
la campagne présidentielle à
floreng je voudrais d'ailleurs sur ce
dossier dalstom dénoncer le double
langage du de l'ancien ministre de
l'Économie Emmanuel Macron qui en 2015
se rend à Belfort et déclare bravache
aucune suppression d'emploi à Belfort et
qui aujourd'hui nous explique que c'est
vrai la méthode est un peu brutale mais
enfin le site est en sur capacité
ferroviaire donc il y a là tout de même
dans les propos d'Emmanuel Macron qui
était en
responsabilité du domaine il n'y a pas
si longtemps une forme de justification
qui ne dit pas son nom et qui évidemment
nous plonge dans l'inquiétude sur ce
site qui est emblématique à bien des
égards il est emblématique d'abord pour
le territoire hein je rappelle que 400
emplois 1600 emplois induits c'est pour
la ville de B fort pour l'agglomération
de Belfort Montbelliard un drame humain
c'est aussi sur le plan industriel un
symbole très fort parce que halstom
c'est tout de même le TGV et au moment
où on parle du TGV du futur il y a tout
de même une ironie extraordinaire de
voir que alstum qui porte des
innovations technologiques
extraordinaires est fragilisé dans la
partie production et la partie
ingénierie donc il y a là véritablement
une une une coïncidence tout à fait
dramatique alors c'est important pour le
territoire je rappelle tout de même que
notre famille politique c'est'est
toujours intéressé à Alstom qu'en 2004
tout de même il y a eu de la part de
Nicolas Sarkozi qui était en en
responsabilité une action tout à fait
volontariste qui a porté ses fruits
puisque l'État est entré au capital à
hauteur de 21,7 % il est toujours
actionnaire à cette hauteurl et Sarkozi
a eu en son temps l'énergie suffisante
pour peser sur les choix industriels de
l'entreprise on voit bien aujourd'hui
que une fois de plus le ce gouvernement
ce président de la République est en
défaut de leadership y compris sur les
sujets industriel on voit que l'État est
dissimulateur puisque
Emmanuel
Macron a prétendu qu'aucun emploi ne
serait supprimé on voit bien qu'il est
pris en défaut par par rapport à cet
engagement et l'État aujourd'hui manque
de stratégie industrielle je rappelle
tout de même que ces derniers mois La
Farge est partie en Suisse Alcatel a été
vendu au Finlandais technipe enfin des
difficultés à RVA des difficultés à EDF
on voit bien qu'il y a en matière
industrielle véritablement un défaut de
pilotage or c'est précisément le rôle
des politiques que de s'engager dans des
dans des dans des stratégies
industrielles puissante ça c'est le
travail des politiques et je dirais
qu'Alstom finalement est
emblématique de de ce que le
gouvernement ne fait pas il faut
approcher les choses en matière
industrielle de façon globale il faut
une lisibilité fiscale il faut une une
simplification du droit du travail il
faut une vraie stratégie il faut créer
les conditions et là on voit bien que ça
n'est pas le ça n'est pas le cas donc
nous serons au républi
extrêmement vigilant sur la gestion de
ce dossier d'Alstom sur lequel pour
l'instant seuls des engagements verbaux
ont été pris et en tout état de cause au
côté des élus locaux au côté des
territoires parce que on néglige souvent
les effets sur les territoires de plans
sociaux ou d'annonces comme celles qui
ont été faites à Alstom et ça nourrit ça
nourrit la la désespérance
ça nourrit le sentiment d'abandon et
tout cela n'est pas bon pour notre pays
n'est pas bon pour notre démocratie et
je reboucle avec le sujet précédent
lorsque vous cumulez des annonces
économiques comme celle-là avec des
stratégies migratoire comme celle que le
le ministre de l'Intérieur s'apprête à
ourdir en secret et bien là on a
véritablement tous les ingrédients de
catastrophe annoncé en terme euh
d'équilibre de nos territoires donc
voilà Alstom un sujet majeur sur lequel
nous demandons au
gouvernement qui est pris en défaut de
volontarisme et
d'anticipation de donner la
démonstration que ces engagements ne
sont pas que de 20
mots
euh puisque j'ai la parole j'enchaîne
sur le
l'école
la alors la semaine dernière c'était la
rentrée scolaire on en a dit quelques
mots la semaine dernière mais je
voudrais
euh y revenir sur deux points tout
d'abord deux grèves la semaine dernière
la semaine de la rentrée de grève ça
donne le ton grève des animateurs
périscolaires et là c'est l'effet
réforme des rythmes scolaires une des
deux réformes majeures du quinquena
deuxième grève les enseignant du collège
alors on nous dit que cette grève a été
peu suivie mais c'est tout de même la 5e
je crois euh donc ça montre bien la
résistance à cette à cette réforme et
puis sur le terrain les enseignants sont
véritablement dégoûté par la mise en
œuvre de cette réforme donc on a là une
rentrée qui euh contredit puissamment
euh le le
discours de la ministre d'éducation du
Premier ministre et du président de la
République qui tente à nous faire croire
que l'éducation a été une grande
réussite sous ce quinquena de deè sujet
scolaire qui a été évoqué cette semaine
c'est tout de même la question de
l'ilettrisme qui revient sur le devant
de la scène j'ajoute que sur cette
question un jeune sur 10 est en
difficulté de lecture un jeune sur 10 et
que cette proportion s'est aggravée
cette dernière année entre 2014 et 2015
donc on touche là tout de même à des
questions assez fondamentales le rôle de
l'école nous le rappelons sans cesse au
républicains c'est tout de même de
donner à aux élèves de France la
capacité cité à maîtriser les
enseignements fondamentaux sans lesquels
aucune réussite scolaire n'est possible
ni aucune insertion sociale et
professionnelle dernier point celui-là
plus dramatique de l'actualité c'est
cette agression à Villefranche Sur saun
sur une jeune fille qui est entre la vie
et la mort alors ce fait nous plonge
dans une dans une un effroid que des
faits comme ceuxlà puissent se produire
avec des protagoniste aussi jeune et euh
on ne peut pas ne pas penser à ce jeune
radicalisé de 15 ans qui s'apprêtait
hein semble-t-il à à commettre des actes
gravissimes là ce sont deux jeunes qui
sont aux prises donc avec une une
tentative de meurtre donc on voit bien
qu'il y a là tout de même des faits qui
sont tout à fait euh tout à fait
préoccupants et si je reviens euh à
l'agression de Villefranche sursun dont
on ne connaît pas encore les CP cause
hein donc je ne me livrerai pas à des
des analyses il faut attendre
l'établissement des faits mais tout de
même nous au Républicain nous plaidons
pour que cette question du traitement de
la violence à l'école soit mieux prise
en compte d'abord ne soit pas niée comme
il est par la ministre d'éducation
nationale il faut faire la lumière sur
la violence à l'école l'école devrait
être un milieu parfaitement préservé de
la violence on voit qu'elle est devenue
un lieu où s'exerce des faits violent et
ceci est tout à fait préoccupant il faut
donc connaître la nature du du problème
et puis ne pas craindre bien que ce soit
l'école de prendre toutes les mesures
qui s'imposent pour et bien rétablir
établir ou rétablir un climat scolaire
qui doit être apaisé car sans climat
scolaire apaisé il ne peut y avoir
d'apprentissage solide voilà les
quelques sujets sur lesquels je voulais
euh revenir
merci donc un petit mot sur le sujet
carcéral à la lumière de la mutinerie
qui s'est déroulé à à vivon puisque cela
soulève évidemment beaucoup de questions
sur la problématique des prisons en
général et notamment de la
surpopulation carcérale qui est un mal
important qui n'est pas nouveau mais qui
s'aggrave et qui génère un malaise
immense auprès de de des gardiens de
prison qui n'ont de cesse de
d'interpeller les politiques sur la très
grande difficultés qu'ils ont à faire
leur métier correctement et à gérer un
milieu de plus en plus violent donc
c'est l'occasion pour nous de rappeler
plusieurs plans de création de place qui
ont été annoncés et exécuté notamment
pour le plan Perben en 2004 avec 11000
places qui se sont sont pour créer une
place de prison entre le moment où on
l'annonce et le moment où on l'inaugure
il s'écoule quand même un certain nombre
d'années environ 10 ans donc depuis 2004
les places que Dominique Perben avait
annoncé se sont
créées ensuite en 2011 le le
gouvernement sous Nicolas Sarkozi avait
annoncé une création de 10000 places
donc je vous rappelle que à l'arrivée du
gouvernement socialiste sous François
Hollande ils ont on décidé immédiatement
que finalement c'était pas forcément
nécessaire de créer ces 10000 places ils
les ont donc supprimé et aujourd'hui ils
nous annonce qu'ils veulent créer 10000
places à la veille des élections
présidentielles donc la moralité de tout
ça c'est quand même qu'on a perdu 4
années 4 années précieuses parce que
quand on on a besoin d'une dizaine
d'années pour aller au bout d'un
programme de de construction de prison
et bien on n' pas de temps à perdre et
donc ben nous je vous rappelle que le le
programme des républicains
préconise une un programme de création
de 20000 places donc quelque chose de
très ambitieux et au-delà de la création
de ces 20000 places il y aura aussi
probablement une réorganisation parce
que certains publics carcéraux comme les
populations radicalisées sont
probablement à traiter d'une manière
différente et il faudra à l'intérieur de
ces créations de place réorganiser cette
population carcérale et soutenir à
nouveau les gardiens de prisson qui sont
je le répète en très grandes difficultés